j'évite bonne étoile
qu'ils s'appellent d'assaisonner
mesdames messieurs alors vous vous
définissez cet album comme celui de la
renaissance musicale et spirituelle
vous dites j'ai retrouvé pendant les
sessions de cet album les sensations que
j'avais quand j'ai fait mon premier
album il ya 15 ans qui s'appelait let
love rule
c'est vrai et je trouve oui c'est tout à
fait vrai la vie est un vraiment un
voyage extraordinaire ressort des
dernières années avant cet album dû
faire face à plusieurs expériences dû
tirer des leçons de la vie joue pas
moins une dépression après la tournée
j'ai dû faire face à plusieurs choses
difficiles mais j'ai réussi à traverser
cet orage j'ai appris beaucoup de choses
sur un mois même sur la vie et après ça
je crois que d'une certaine manière j'ai
une renaissance c'est la raison pour
laquelle je les appelais battus homme à
terre alors c'est vrai que la chanson
lady fait référence à votre aventure
avec nicole kidman
or vous travaillez qui vous a dit ça
j'ai tout balancier
aw à mentir je ne dis rien
réponse non je connaissais la réponse
avant de vous poser la question mais je
suis obligé de vous la poser ouais vous
avez eu des tas de conquêtes amoureuses
duquel vous avez parlé
vanessa paradis madonna on ne sait pas
trop kylie minogue natalie imbruglia
nicole kidman
alors on cherche toujours à savoir
évidemment quel est votre secret pour
ginette garcin pour séduire toute
jeunette garçon mutique au mans c'est là
c'est la wii me scotche puisque ginette
garcin
moi je n'ai lu je suis plus haut et je
les les j'aime bien la mecque
non mais vous avez sûrement un secret
pour avoir ce succès acquis sur avec les
femmes vous avez un secret alors
dernièrement vous avez dit dans la
presse que vous portiez jamais sous
vêtements est ce que vous pensez que ça
ça aide avec les femmes
amy adore watts est non je ne parle pas
mais qu'est ce que ça a à voir avec le
reste je sais pas non je ne suis que moi
même toi non plus voulu dire moi j'en
porte pas mais je n'ai pas le même
succès dit ça ça vous ça vous dégoûte un
maquis porte pas de sous-vêtements vos
parce que ni les nîmois n'emportant je
le dis tout de suite ok c'est pas bruit
c'est pas un problème heureusement bien
et moi on a deux beaux calbète bernard
blanc col ouvert le sien oui blanc col
ouvert toujours bernard très bonne vanne
dirige temps donne une deuxième vie
merci au nom non ils veulent une carte
de grosses culte mais sait très bien
qu'au fond de toi tu es comme ça tel
quoi toi non maintenant j'ai la carte de
bons clients et avant que ça c'est là tu
aimes kimadia bernard pour lui donner
une carte aussi qu'est ce qui lui donne
à bernard une bonne carte avec toi
voyons voir carte de mauvais clients non
non je n'ai plus de
c'est le cas des collectors banon pas
bernard donc pas de sous-vêtements et
est vite je porte jamais de parfums vous
mettez jamais de parfois vous dites ça
pue est-ce que c'est compatible les deux
méchants les choses du gang
ce programme c'est incroyable impasse de
la philosophie au parfum aussi
maintenant j'adore
alors non je ne passe on s'est tous
voila je peins je vois la multi qui
portent des parfums te le demande
d'arrêter non les finissants de l'eau
n'a pas de problème mais l'argent qu'ils
portent pas de parfum ça vous préférez
qu'ils emportent exemple elle s'en fout
du monde ça embête je crois c'est
quelqu'un intéressant ça quelque chose
d'autre je serais pas en train de se
hisser sur le toit et la grande qualité
de lenny kravitz peut le dire la grande
qualité de lenny kravitz en dehors des
chansons qui fait bien entendu c'est
qu'il peut se retenir c'est à dire il
peut rester deux mois sans faire l'amour
un prêt de deux mois sans faire la bonne
et là ça fait trois mois il est chaud
c'est vrai dans l'est ni lait ni c'est
pas le genre à se jeter sur les filles
bêtement comme nous tu vois c'est vrai
ligne en deux mois tout le monde gagne
je fais ça ou d'où vous sortez faire un
faux mais bon il ya des époques où il
faut faire une pause
ouais et vraiment se concentrer sur soi
même se concentrait sur sarthe et
ritualité le chiffre d'affaires
nos sexe le sexe
alors lenny kravitz va devenir encore
plus séduisant parce qu'il à faire du
cinéma il va devenir une vedette de
cinéma
il va jouer dans un film qui s'appelle
barbecue ce bar mitsva c'est un film qui
raconte l'histoire d'un musicien comme
vous d'ailleurs qui est né d'un père
blanc juif et d'une mère noire
il s'est plutôt semi autobiographique
comme on grandit entre deux cultures
c'est vraiment la façon dont j'ai grandi
à new york
alors c'est pas du tout un film musical
c'est un film un petit peu dans l'esprit
un petit peu woody allen c'est ça mais
c'est plutôt comment toulouse y allait
en fait je suis réalisateur mais je j'ai
demandé à woody allen qui soit comme
réalisateur il m'aide qui me donne un
coup de main moi ça fait mal vous avez
en rendrez vous en parlez vous dans
votre bouquin de vous dire des
conversations extraordinaire et woody
allen on s'est rencontrés on a oui on a
on a discuté pendant une après-midi le
script de la conversation et la
personnage magnifique et poétique est
tellement persuadé surtout à l'époque
c'est ce qui m'avait frappé tellement
persuadé qu'il était un maudit en
amérique
je me rappelle c'était sale bête en 93
94 et jolie avait dit est ce que vous
pouvez pas donner un coup de main en
amérique pour alerter l'opinion sur la
guerre de bosnie sur sarajevo
il m'a dit écoutez moi je suis prêts
bien sûr à le faire mais je vais je
rendrai à sarajevo le plus mauvais
service qu'ils soient car je suis
tellement impopulaire en amérique il
suffit que je me mêle d'affaires pour la
plomber un essai telles images qu'il
avait à l'époque c'était tôt
au maximum de son de cette histoire
miles qu'on y avait collé sur le dos
ouais arrête toi toi il est en train il
va il va vous filmez on est là faites
attention il est gelé vue c'est la
dernière mode
oh là là t'as vu ça mais remonter volume
eric montalvo services publics arrêt
comment je suis là je veux dire il
établira un mouvement qui lui avait
donné des ordres alors les nids sur
l'irak vous avez pris des positions très
anti guerre vous avez même enregistré
une chanson avec une popstar irakienne
qui s'appelle qu'animal saillir avec un
libanais et un palestinien est la
chanson qui s'appelle we want peace
hé hé
il
c'est une chanson qui s'appelle we want
peace on peut trouver sur le site rock
devota vous était contre la guerre en
irak ne va pas vous rendre très
populaire ça vous etats-unis non non pas
vraiment en fait
aux etats unis les gens pas très bien
accueilli cette déclaration surtout
qu'il y avait une machine de propagande
qui détruisait tout sur son passage et
donc si vous étiez américain contre la
gorge contre la gare vous n'étiez pas
patriote vous n'apportez pas votre
soutien votre pays et dans le new york
post ils sont inutiles
il y avait ma photo à côté de celle de
saddam hussein en disant que nous étions
en écosse
tout simplement parce que j'avais chanté
une chanson dj nous voulons la paix avec
un chanteur irakien sous n'importe quoi
on va accueillir maintenant